لا تنخدع بهذا الهدوء
صحيح انه لا قتال عنيفا سجل مع هدنه
الايام السبعه
لكن الاشتباكات المتفرقه والضربات الجويه
استمرت
استمرت الى الحد الذي اقلق وسط اتفاق جده
الذين يراقبون الهدنه من بعد
يشير بيان سعودي امريكي المشترك الى حدوث
انتهاكات من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لوقف اطلاق النار الجديد مما اعاق
بشكل كبير ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
واستعاده الخدمات الاساسيه في البلاد
البيان حث الطرفين على مواصله النقاش
للوصول الى اتفاق بشان تبديد وقف اطلاق
النار الحالي
فذكرما سيوفر مزيدا من الوقت للجهات
الانسانيه الفاعله للقيام بعملها الحيوي
ما الذي يحول الان دون ذلك
يؤكد الجيش السوداني التزامه باتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار قصير الامد بل ويبدي استعدادا
لبحث امكانيه الموافقه على تمديده بما
يتضمنه من ترتيبات انسانيه
ذاته الاستعداد تؤكده قوات الدعم السريع
لكنها تقول انها تواصل مراقبه الهدنه
لاختبار مدى التزام الطرف الاخر وجديته
اختبار النيات هذا لا يقتصر كما يبدو على
طرفي النزاع الساعه كل منهما لتعزيز موقعه
وصفوفه
يختار الجيش هذا التوقيت بالذات لاتهام
المبعوث الاممي الخاص بممارسه التزوير
والتضليل اثناء قيادته عمليه سياسيه انتهت
الى الاقتتال في منتصف ابريل الماضي
بقوه دافعت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن الرجل
قالت في بيان انها تدعم الامم المتحده
وعمل الممثل الخاص لامينها العام فولكر
بيرتيس كما اعربت عن قلقها من رساله
القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي تطالب فيها
باستقالته
هذا جدل دبلوماسي لا يحجب تعقيدات الميدان
ومن التعقيدات ما حمله القتال الممتد غربا
الى دارفور حاكم الاقليم مني اركو من ناوي
الذي يتزعم حركه تحرير السودان اتهم جهات
لم يسميها بالتفريط في السلامه وحقوق
المواطنين وتخريب المؤسسات القوميه عمدا
من ناوي دعا سكان الاقليم بمختلف فئاتهم
الى حمل السلاح لحمايه ممتلكاتهم واكد ان
ما سماها حركات الكفاح
ستساندهم كلام يفهم السودانيون معانيه لكن
مكتبه حاكم دارفور يؤكد مع ذلك التزام
الحياد التام في القتال الجاري بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ويدعو المكتب الى وقف الحرب
والدخول في حوار مباشر يفضي الى حل سياسي
شامل